[Music]
this episode is sponsored by ren a
website where you calculate your carbon
footprint you can also sign up to make a
monthly contribution to offset your
carbon footprint or support rainforest
protection projects
[Music]
blepharism have appeared on our channel
several times before in fact this
channel got its start thanks to a video
that james our master of microscopes
once posted of a blepharisma dying
around 3 million people watched that
video including me your host hank green
so if you enjoy this channel you can
thank that dead blepharisma
but perhaps you should wait for another
day to thank them because in about 10
seconds you're gonna watch a blepharisma
explode here it is
glowing with autofluorescence underneath
uv light you can see its oblong shape
and oral groove outlined in red
but not for long
the red becomes brighter and brighter
but it also looks like it's starting to
expand
and then suddenly the walls of the
blepharism burst
the organism
popping like a crimson balloon
the blepharism bubbles and pours into
its surroundings and it all happens
within a matter of seconds
let's watch it again
[Music]
[Music]
dead or dying microbes are a common
enough site in our journey through the
microcosmos and there are many potential
culprits behind these deaths predators
accidents environmental changes the
inevitable march of life into death but
the culprit this time well
it was us
us and the uv light that is part of our
new fluorescence microscope upgrade and
our uv light has been very exciting for
us in particular it's allowed us to look
for methanogens or archaea which
sometimes take up residence inside
protists under normal light it's hard to
tell the tiny archaea and the tiny
bacteria apart but under uv light the
archaea will shine blue
so uv can reveal new aspects of the
micro cosmos but if you've ever fallen
asleep on a beach or just stayed out in
the sun of it too long you may have also
experienced
the darker side of uv light
no one wants a sunburn but fortunately
we have defenses like hair and melanin
and sunscreen which can block or absorb
uv rays before they cause further damage
in our cells
we also and this is crucial have more
than one cell so if some of them die
which when you get a sunburn they do the
rest of our bodies can live on
not all organisms have these sorts of
protections or if they do they're
designed for exposure to the sun not the
intense scrutiny of our uv light
[Music]
so when james wants to haunt archaea he
has to be careful he can quickly shine
the uv light to see if anything blue
appears but he has to quickly shut it
off
because as we've seen even a few seconds
of exposure to the uv light will kill
off his pond buddies
we want to note that as we said earlier
death is a common reality of the
microcosmos we just usually prefer to
walk in on a microbe dying rather than
being the cause of death but for this
episode we decided to make an exception
and use our uv light for an extended
period of time with the knowledge that
it would kill the microbe we were
watching because these explosions
illustrate the cost of doing business
with light
the word for this business is photo
toxicity
death by light and while it can happen
under monochromatic light the particular
wavelength and intensity of our uv light
makes it much more harmful to our
organisms than our other red blue or
green light sources
this death starts with excitation
when the light hits the organism it can
potentially excite chemical structures
inside the cell sending electrons up and
down and producing fluorescent colors in
the process but the colors aren't the
only thing that gets created if there's
oxygen around it will react with the
excited fluorescent molecule creating
what are known as reactive oxygen
species
in biology reactive oxygen species are
byproducts of different cellular
processes that metabolize oxygen which
can make them part of normal life there
are even reactive oxygen species that
are involved in signaling pathways but
the reactive in their name is key to
what makes an excess amount of them
dangerous
if you are an organism and you are there
are a lot of reactions you want to have
happen in your cells you want your dna
to link together correctly you want your
enzymes to find the right substrates
but reactive oxygen species are happy to
react with all of those molecules too
damaging them and getting in the way of
the chemistry that we need
to survive
what phototoxicity will look like
depends on the organism and the light
being directed at it
[Music]
for the organisms we've been showing
here like this homolozoan the overall
effect of this intense uv light seems to
be unanimous the cell swells up and
bursts open like a galaxy erupting on
our slide
but while the overall effect is the same
the internal machinations are likely
different triggered by a complex
interplay of different chemicals that
nonetheless react to our light source in
a similar catastrophic fashion
while we're not sure of the culprits
behind the homolozoan's death we can
identify one of the chemicals that
likely sets off the blepharisma's death
it's the reddish pigment molecule called
blepharisman that gives the ciliate its
color under more normal circumstances
outside of the uv light you can see the
membrane-bound pigments neatly
distributed along the rows that stretch
from one end of the blepharism to the
other
but under our uv light and with oxygen
in the environment the blepharisman
reacts to form a reactive oxygen species
and death follows quickly from there
but while toxic in our experiment we
should note that the blepharisman serves
a key purpose for the blepharisma
defense these pigment molecules are
toxic to some of blepharitis predators
in both the light and the dark
that makes the pigment somewhat like uv
light necessary for survival yet also a
delicate negotiation
but in the same way that we manage our
relationship with the sun scientists
have learned ways to manage these
phototoxic reactions
they've had to in order to understand
how we can use fluorescence microscopy
to study cells and organisms they've
learned how to modulate wavelength and
intensity and duration along with many
other factors to wield light in a way
that better serves their purposes
in the case of the blepharisma for
example scientists found that using a
moderate light for around one hour
wasn't much of a problem for them but
with more time under the light the cells
would eventually die
it's easy to think of the microcosmos as
a separate world from us even when we
know that the microscope is a bridge
between large and small
but these deaths at the hand of our
supposed bridge
are a cautionary sign that we are
encountering microbes in a world that is
both natural and manufactured at the
same time
the way that we light that world
impacts the way we see the organisms and
it also shapes their lives
reminding us that they are stronger
often than we can fathom
but fragile nonetheless
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
ren for supporting this episode of
journey to the micro cosmos ren is a
place where you can calculate your
carbon footprint then offset it by
funding projects that plant trees and
protect rainforests we're gonna need a
lot of different approaches to stop the
climate crisis and this is one way that
you can learn more about your carbon
contribution and take some action i took
their climate quiz answering a few
questions about my lifestyle so that i
could see what my carbon footprint was
then they showed me some ways i could
start reducing it but no one can reduce
their carbon footprint to zero so by
using ren i was able to offset what i
had left once you sign up you'll receive
updates from the tree planting
rainforest protection and other projects
you support and also we have partnered
with ren to plant 10 extra trees for the
first 100 people to sign up using the
link in the description
the people on your screen right now
those are our patreon patrons they're
the people who support this channel
every single episode so that we can
continue
diving into this wonderful and
mysterious world so if you love what we
do here these are some of the people to
thank and if you want to become one of
those people all you got to do is go to
patreon.com
journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss and why
wouldn't you you can check out jam and
germs on instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you